In 2018, Michigan State’s ex-president,
Lou Anna Simon, was forced from office
after the horrific Larry Nassar sexual abuse scandal.
Then, the university handed Simon a
sweetheart retirement deal.
Simon’s failure to address a documented
and long-standing pattern of criminal abuse
was apparently not cause enough to trim
the cords of her golden parachute.
Unfortunately, getting a pass for being asleep at the switch seems pretty much the norm
when it comes to leaders at America’s colleges.
Recall the spring 2019 “Varsity Blues”
college admissions scandal.
The parents and the sleaze-merchants who orchestrated
the scheme are facing serious repercussions.
The oblivious campus mandarins who presided over the corruption? They’ve gotten off scot-free.
It’s no wonder that polling shows
Americans on both the left and right
are losing faith in higher education.
The industry's leaders demand
more and more public support.
The least we should expect is that these
same leaders be held accountable
when they betray the public trust.
Do you think university leaders should be more accountable for what happens on their watch?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.